alright ladies and gentlemen it's hell
Wednesday okay only Wednesday it's a
gloomy thought hey why do you start it
like you've been working on radio yeah
you started well now I just let you're
pretty bloody it's bright down we're
here in studio hey let me talk gloomy is
that it's Hell where we'll come pushing
up on that gloom June gloom ladies don't
know why you started doing it you just
jump on a very everybody I mean it's
like I'm coming to Irvine this weekend
get your cars now now Sunday get your
tickets now tone don't walk run run to
the box of Linderman they are going
super fast it's Ryan
Callen live and in person and I'll tell
you think speaking a live in-person trip
Brennan I'm super happy to be here on
this Wednesday our Salmons looking
fantastic got her hair all kinds of all
kinds of mounded up on the top of her
head she's got a wraparound and have no
idea how a girl does that but I improve
I approve and then we got chin our
standard chin generators he's a giant
Korean man who's our rock he's just a
big old piece of granite
nothing changes he just does his [ __ ]
job all kinds of quiet with those long
fingers and that beautiful singing voice
come on oh come on down chin and show us
your dong all right he in it wit I've
noticed that the present past too much I
just noticed IndieGoGo in the yo heck
everybody it's Brian Kelly it's good to
be unlike many things I changed a little
bit I'm becoming as you get older you
get more cheesy I was I was at the this
is the one long she was running secret
so my dad God loved me 77 my dad will go
to a restaurant and he'll say you know
the woman will come over and I'll say
the waiter yeah yeah dad the waiter and
this is to us it's a woman he'll say my
son will have my moviestar son we'll
have the sets and such and I'm going to
I know I'm a little handsome for you
here so it might be old it does every
concentrate whatever he does well guess
who does that now guess you do that yeah
I'll be [ __ ] like it's not sorry if
you're probably getting lost in my eyes
I well you know whatever you've been up
for years sure have but you know when
you know what your go-to is I know you
think I'm a bodybuilder but I will have
the carrot cake in like yeah I could
almost beat you to it I get nothing I
get nothing no thank you yeah I'm a
bodybuilder I won't be having the carrot
cake
and haha very good what else yet or how
about the woman in where were we
she was like you are your body builder
I'll do you talk about English Chicago
yeah no no no we're not Minnesota not a
bodybuilder well not on I'm not at a
convention here how about the other day
we have one of our favorite restaurants
will there do some work those two girls
sit next to those older women like so
what do you guys don't yeah I don't I'm
like I was just doing some where's my
friend here just you know very very cool
I sell dog supply money that's cool yeah
I like dogs so anyways Bren she was out
what are you doing Brian's all huh and
you love how I can I just shot who go
right to your phone do it nothing drives
me more I was ringing at her Jason's
landing we were seeing at a communal
bench and she was just right there in
front of me and sometimes you're just
like it's like on a plane when you keep
reading and they just keep talking to
you but there you can do anything to a
damn thing you can like dancing yep well
there it is I'm just like goddammit one
time I was getting my makeup done and
this guy was making doing my makeup like
this and kind of a macho guy it's very
rare you see a kind of a macho kind of
straight man in makeup others in how it
did you get him and you know but and I'm
not saying but but typically it's kind
of my experiences it's it's more rare
Amanda what's the line the most the time
the male's make up do yes or if Emma is
fun yes there's nothing wrong without it
not at all nothing so uh he's doing my
makeup and he's gay it's funny because
he's one of those guys where when he's
doing your makeup he's he looks like
he's about to run away race slowly ya
know when he ever see somebody at the
start line they're not in the craft at
the start line and they got their legs
spread and they're about to run oh yeah
you know that's how we down on my makeup
well I like that yeah hence guy and get
that the dead bat and the woman who's
also a makeup woman she's just talking
to him and she just keeps talking and
it's like 6:30 in the morning and he's
trying to get me done and he's trying to
get he's trying to give me a scar so
it's kind of an intricate thing and he's
got to get somebody I'll doing work he's
doing work and she keeps talking about
asking questions and finally he just as
he's doing he goes he couldn't have it
because lady you gotta stop talking to
me
and she goes what you gotta stop talk to
me I can't focus and because he couldn't
and she I'm sorry sorry
and I fight so hard for me to see with
those people other day I like to go so
your fight I got something like that and
I go back talking you and then he'll
just keep fishing keep fish I'm like oh
my god take a [ __ ] hit no one's
better at this than our boy Todd Feldman
I was at this party with him
he knows everyone that everyone wants
something from and this guy's in the
military but let me stop you there we
have a lunch on Thursday right me guys
he famous you know big time dude engages
I think so he was Gary I remember we
have lunch on Thursday let's talk about
then because I'm big right now I'm
talking my friend so we're gonna do on
Thursday great okay great very I never
lose someone very grandage the time
situation like that ever yes and it's
not mean it's very dragging strike eight
let's go through this on Tuesday onesie
but right now I'm enjoying my time with
my friend I wish I were stitch to see
like sometimes celebrities like say
prison or someone like whoever it might
be when they go to restaurants that
somewhere in Beverly Hills or it's a
hangout spot okay I know why most guys
don't do this because what happens is
there are people that will come up and
try to sell you [ __ ] now just come up
and tell you about their eyeglass store
they look at they got a card everybody
is coming at your work is that were
someone's like did you say flying cars
you like give me a card I'll give me
good i sat next to Quincy Jones one time
this went my second year in MADtv and he
took us out and I was sitting with
Quincy Jones and what was incredible was
how many people came up to him and how
many people were were pitching him one
idea after another I was incredibly I've
never seen like it what was amazing
about him and I said to him he would he
would take their hand they shave their
hand he'd bring them in to him and he
would put his head basically on their
head and listen and then go say
something like clip I'll keep that in
mind man let let me know as coach but he
do it really quickly and I said to him I
said you are so good at navigating this
you're just kind of pushing these guys
off and he said he's a Bloggie head
crowd he said no I'm actually listening
to see if there's a good idea and if
there isn't I kind of just say all right
Thank You Man
but isn't that when they when he's there
with them you feel like you're the only
person were like I thought he and I were
going to be best friends yeah I was like
oh well should I move in your guest
house that we're buddy well Steve Harvey
beg to differ Steve Arthur yeah no one
[ __ ] look at me I'm on set yep
Howard Stern roasted him so bad whoo
quickie oh man turn Steve Harvey out
early what the [ __ ] it you know he was
famous like you barely got a show here
that 420 fear are we talking about I've
never had to do that he wrote them so
bad it was hilarious man Quincy Jones
the biggest a huge lady man right later
and ever since there was this beautiful
girl there blonde girl was hanging
around so I cuz I'm not even an idiot I
was 27 and I I'm some actor who's nobody
knows I go into predator mode and I'm
like come over sit here come sit next to
us comes a Quincy Jones this is quite
Sheila therefore Quincy Quincy go yeah
Quincy goes man you're bringing in
reruns that's channel 13 channel 13 in
New York baby yeah yeah that's counselor
thing man you bring in a real visit I
was like what are you x how would you
work over here and you got you got you
have my rerun coming and you invite her
she got into you I was like oh he said
hey he was so funny learned called let
me run channel 13 really was crawls like
[ __ ] I want to learn that dude how about
think of it I don't know I hope I an out
the great Quincy Jones who's 84 now I'm
sure you're good how about this morning
I was running on the stairs and this you
know you passed my listing vevo all the
time
I'm pasteurized I need it did you know
just get dudes Jackie I seen there all
the time and it always looks like he has
something on his nose like I'm like I'm
like like a booger or I don't know
what's going on tomorrow and then we get
to it may be a mole but I got to pay
remember that immediately now you big
handsome do like big dude cut in but not
young not I mean he might be like a kid
genetics like I might be 50 he's up this
robe or some gray hair yeah I would say
he's between 45 and 55 but phenomenal
shape tan is [ __ ] in all Lululemon
what's usually red flags that's
interesting that's an interesting thing
so we get to the top and I'm stretching
getting done and he goes hey brother see
here all the title what's up man and I
finally close enough look
it's a nose ring well sir he can't now
let that you can't be 5000 forties with
a nose ring right extra Lenny Kravitz
unless you're living another then even
though a little while hold off he can
blow it up but Johnny Depp is still
dressing like he's not with the nosing
though a wizard no Johnny Depp just like
you Jasper Oh 24/7 yeah and as usually
2/3 or whatever he is that now it's
getting a little bit edge on Johnny
Tremain necklaces a little bit know this
dude bit this dude had a earring change
like every time you won't deal out I was
going that's Mary
oh yeah I immediately judged yeah I've
seen guys within are one of the bet in a
spray tan and then the all Lululemon
that little red like you cannot even
trust house Sunday Club if you have an
atomic level no you can't have nose in
your not interrupt house Sunday Club
which last time you saw a male in the
know things besides lenny kravitz go III
and assume they're all the time if he
listeners who do me like [ __ ] my boy my
turn lemon run away in Seattle Rob who
owns amped CrossFit which I recommend
you go and see how to awesome gym he is
a CrossFit instructor young very good
looking at no thing I use black and
Jewish he's got some mix or meant either
way like that he's this really good
looking guy he's got a nose ring but but
the way he goes off if you're in your
20s you're like in your across fair he
gets away with nope I actually
personally I asked her a ttle I like I
like nose rings in on black guys some
guys can pull it off on black on black
guys to me uh if you've got that sort of
like no hair on your body and you're
kind of styling like the Lenny Kravitz
look then I can I can I can you just I
just trying to battle them forever then
you just [ __ ] not with a guy my age
with the spray tan no there's no problem
hey no this here's a buck nuts for any
mail list in this [ __ ] show if you
have a nose ring you're not too
popularly Krauts take that [ __ ] out
bring up a whole point for model grab my
ring on your shut up bring it out
immediately and I don't okay hold on
don't particularly listen to me how
about this you're right okay now nose
ring is one thing and let me ask you
this what if it's a small tasteful
diamond stud no no that's a ring that
does be a nose piercing you see and I'm
today you got no
time for any of it no you cannot do that
unless you play a guitar like let me
grab it okay so you're Bob Marley how
about how about that Dave Navarro he can
get away with it yeah man I'd be scared
to be alone Dave Navarro to enjoy
something I like and I'm like and I'm
like they want to suck my dick Lenny's
got his Lenny's got his nipple pierced
now that's another that's a big he's got
two nose rings hold up real quick though
that's when he crap I didn't kravitz he
destroys that another black black and
Jewish guy see I'm gonna care of my boy
Rob he looks good in it Oh across
leather yeah can't do that
I like cornrows on guys to even if
they're white I don't know why unless
you have gay bro it might be blight
listen let's just let's just go in Vitor
Belfort used to have that J I know but
let's just go over the last couple
statements said yeah you down for nose
ring on men if they're young and you
like cornrows on white dudes oh I mean
it son you gay and then you got to beat
a deep v-neck on it let me late gang up
say it like that nobody gay no don't say
gay hate and I'm just listening try to
be PC yeah guy but when you go to see
Allen do the shows yeah yeah and they're
doing careful a wad careful that one
answered your kipping it on it yeah
careful careful that guy would be the
nose ring yeah you're funny
hey hey man I'm not answering all your
crime not in a court of law
right now on I'll just love this child
we work out sometimes I know I get a ten
like you guys you'll get that nice
Seattle kasi yeah funny I'm not gonna
you can't ask me a question we just work
out he opens his gym amped brain we we
train he brings me through a light
workout then you open that old that
you'll Beach for hey hey what the [ __ ]
is this a lot of questions I know man
why are you all like why you're just
chin why'd you scream get in here he
says when you look at me walk while you
look at me at the top of your bras right
now I feel like you're looking for a guy
in grinder with a white dude with
cornrows and a nose ring I speak I mean
if you shut up my door I was drawing
cooked corn rows of white yeah that's
another thing you cannot do
bring up Vitor Belfort with cornrows
back when he's on trt look fantastic
I like dreads on guys on what else huh
short Tavian toys yeah yeah you looked
awesome back there you go there for a
while you're gonna go huh ah he look
like a bad [ __ ]
same with your AIA I like it that I
liked it that detour gets away with if
you're a fighter you get you get you
need corn nuts getting get corn nuts
mmm it's an honor had of two didn't he
yeah for a little bit Wow veto how about
Vitor fights this weekend our boy named
our Court God Battle of just the old
legends that's how my board ends for you
yeah I was listening someone breaks him
down and just like you know both over
the hill I'm just like I'm out if you
fat if you go back if you rewind
six years ago you time out two of the
biggest stars in the world correct and
then here they are now and it's there
just a flicker on the main card just way
I guess that's what fighting right
fighting you know at the end of the day
you a dressing on how big the deal Nate
was and how big of a deal Vitor is and
yeah they and I hear bringing it it's
just that glint I mean just that ah both
old I mean it's a tough fight Vitor and
Brazil can be tough to beat Nate will
Cheney now Mike holy [ __ ] like just a
lack respecting you break down those
cards I think I did it older I think as
people get older no matter who they are
to the day their biggest fear is that
they're becoming useless like nobody
wants them nobody needs them right I
think I've heard that from older people
like the one of the things my
grandmother's really young so you tell
no I am I wonder why I told you what my
grandmother was with her friends and
everything I was a young man I remember
she said they were just talking together
and they didn't really know that I was
listening and she said I remember when
men stop looking at me remember that and
women when I I remember that I mean when
they stopped looking it was that was
when you know you were getting over and
I went before a fighter who Nathan
fought for World Championship multiple
time world champion and then Vitor
Belfort you know the Phenom did fight
forever it's just so because they're
still in it they're still in it you know
Vitor to slop for Tyler like a few years
ago yeah it's not easy man it it really
is but that's that's out you know that's
how the sport goes after a while you
stick around
how about the fact that more into Jesus
though this is a battle of Jesus oh it
is they're both so religious who loves
Jesus more we write out know now we're
gonna find out who Jesus Jesus loves
more you know what is uh you got a
couple of Christian soldiers in that
octagon God soldiers yeah
got a couple you got a couple the Lord's
soldiers in there and they're both
fighting it's a tough fight there's
really a lot of chests crossing before
they go and after and there'll be a lot
of praying before and after I'm looking
forward to it how about Vitor goes this
isn't my last fight I'm gonna leave the
UFC and French go to rise and get Jack
to the oh that's gonna be fun I think
Nate and Vitor should say [ __ ] you sada
both get juice to the gills get cut
light each other well they both get you
know this is both the last hurrah both
of them see might as well you know
Bigfoot Silva went back on TRT when he's
winning again now right I don't know if
he's winning but I know you went back on
like well I'm pretty sure he won his
last one I think he I think he's won
every fight since because now he's back
on TRT what's weird with him he's the
guy who needed it yeah yeah I kind of
but it's not yeah is trying to them
because we'll be giant yeah young virile
TRT his chin was like ridiculous on tear
tear in fact that crazy draw with Mark
Hunt you know why that is why would this
tear idea give you a better chance could
not tell you I don't know idea I don't
fish strengthens the muscles in your
neck or whatever does be with you guys
on TV but skies off DRT yeah I could
give you a million example oh yeah
oh yeah I wonder what it is I don't know
I really don't I wonder if it's um I
have no idea have you heard people say
that it like getting knocked out is
sometimes it can be a mental thing
well no although what they say is that
getting knocked out your body starts to
learn after you take enough punishment
your body doesn't want anymore the
punishment it'll shut sighing downs you
yeah but that's not for multiple
multiple knocked out yeah it's going to
get easier turn that button off yeah but
I wonder why TRT I don't hope so I don't
know I don't and maybe it doesn't maybe
it's just that they're so aggressive
that they're not getting hit their
reaction times dollar
no you know you
yeah Big Foot verse smart caught and
he's eaten shots I mean still slow yeah
you look at all you look at Vitor but
your name or car look at all these guys
Minh all the name a guy yeah mm-hmm
I guess is not Oh God jung-hwa so you
lost that you know one when was that
allows November he thought since then he
just fought I don't think they've
updated it probably what a way to make a
living getting hit but yeah before that
he's lost naka loudest man but he's on
the juice
yeah she's fought since then that's
crazy what can he do men one day and I
have [ __ ] I was going to do the for
the first time in my comedy career else
you can do the hat trick tonight I can
do three shows back to back to back
Wow I can't do it no no I had some
personal family issues had to cancel him
cymatics man it's literally one my I'm I
have a gold thing and I literally would
to do the hat trick is one of them I was
we marked it up tonight been planning
for a while can three shows two shows
back back to back
wow I know I got a show I'm doing that
show can we talk about your dog a little
more because your dog is now in its
third day of training and it's kind of
unbelievable because they West is his
name Nick light Nick white because I was
skeptical I was like I think this guy's
using dogs that have been trained before
and then I start seeing testimonials of
people who gave them their dogs if they
had them for like Ryan Reynolds this
dude is these dog I'm telling you this
guy is these dogs are literally this dog
is doing like pirouettes with standing
on one foot it's doing calculus and it
really is literally like I mean you
decide about one of the dogs talking you
know if you look at baby top five in the
world I mean he even bit those guys that
know how a dog thinks like I've always
loved dogs by a [ __ ] about dogs I
realized
let me tell you like know how a dog
thinks I asked them because he send me
up like I thought seven videos on my
phone since we did gently updates
non-stop what's going with the dog last
cycle I crazy me out the hell do you do
it he's like dude I've been up for so
long yeah and he goes remember to with
your dog I have for six a week basically
when he was in the Secret Service he
said they would do this with dogs
seven days a week for five months in
situ matter he - [ __ ] yeah he was I've
literally been doing the master they did
about when he says the word like when he
has a dog in a down stay and then like
so anytime you do that I my dog I work
on my dog with a down state if I go huh
if I do that it like I make it is it's
alright he can go pizza or Johnny you
can say anything any you said it my dog
my hit break unless he says break it has
to be the exact way that's incredible
the dog can like that you also have a
high level working dog but that's why
some egos look at him testimonial he's
done it with lad she said it like that's
that's the cliche like doing your work
the Malinois don't know any that's why I
said I'm like damn it's great that Mel
was smart he goes yeah they're super
smart and he goes the thing with the
Malin wise switch this one it's been on
a ranch free able to just roam around
when the reader okay he goes this was
actually harder than my other dogs wow
she is zero well they also have a lot of
slide so high drive dogs are harder
sometimes to Train yes and he upset so
third things and she didn't have a high
drive that's why she's able to be placed
in my home because there was own mal was
with the Tufts dog in the world
watch out they've been known to bite and
not like I see all the comps and
everyone's a dog I swear all my friends
are dog experts I see it all over
i'ma listen to the expert the actual
expert the guy who reader the guys
contain a dog in one day well talk about
the guy makes a living and made millions
off training dog oh and listen him he
vetoes it I'll I don't I won't listen to
anyone a dog you should know you can't
into the guy then you find out people
they really like I like dog do you like
that yeah yeah we don't know why I don't
in Ian's about dog so do I hear today
we're know we have any questions I got a
lying answers for you guys I've read
some stuff cuz I because I've watched
some videos because I've had dogs I
don't know a goddamn thing
and that's why does if you think I have
been trying to train my dog yeah since
I've been watching those videos yeah
Doublemint it's a different level
different level miss different level I
like anything else like anything else to
do it you know there's certain people I
can
I remember this woman used to make this
insane rice it's going to sound like a
weird story but she's Armenian and she
had this restaurant and she's make this
right I got a house I hate this rice and
this rice I'll give a [ __ ] what anybody
says the best Armenian / Iraqi
I've ever had a month so I go how do you
make it so she starts to tell me and her
husband to that it doesn't matter what
he makes she could tell you how to make
it you could draw your diagrams you
would never make it like this I said but
she's telling me she goes I know I know
she'll give you every detail every
detail you can never do paint-by-numbers
this is a feeling there's a touch which
is on her salon okay that's her thing in
her life it means there's a reason why
you know you reach out to those people
and my favorite is with you and when I
go yeah he's a black belt or he's if
anything you know what
but how did he hold it you know how do
you do this it doesn't matter he does
Jiu Jitsu or boxing as a recreational
sport that other guy did it as his job
was his job well you saw that was your
time my fashion alter the guy I felt for
some professional laughs is it I am like
everything else like everything else
kids would you go to dinner lattice all
picture you and young Stevie blue we
went to one of my favorite places in the
world and Silver Lake called Cafe Stella
I did all kajoor would have it a la casa
dwell and then I went oh I love that
place
we went there with that as well it's so
good oh and and Stevie was looking in
his fridge he's like I think I'm gonna
eat salad tonight so hungry I want to do
and he gets text me wanna come eat you
know I was gonna feed him some serious
serious food he knows pump with
challenges they too cracked open a
special bottle of wine did he or did he
go to will Stewart no no you're with
will Marshall anew yep throwing a chair
broken I had a little juice in it Chad
Colson is a writer he's written a lot of
TV shows and a lot of books like what
shows he wrote that judge with Kate
Walsh that went first season but he's
written a bunch of other stuff I don't
know he's in there got another show now
he's always got a show and that rule
does the timid process so time something
Tim Marshall him Tommy Blanca one day
you had Tommy Solaris that's because I
was doing an interview yesterday he was
doing the Alpha Chi know Robert DeNiro
they have a talk show he's playing
opportunities playing Robert De Niro
playing both of them and I was his guest
and they never asked one question thing
like wow we've got we've
I'm doing terrible but we got Bryan
Callen here man the good guy
yeah there's Minter actor hate to be
nicer I know I know I know they wanna
work you're talking on the way you're
you're redoing what you guys did yes
they're in the bus he's but anyway I was
like he's so good at doing impressions
my Robert Mira an opportunity seen
something I was like listening watching
this guy [ __ ] do a little best for
the best did he say chips Nathan instead
or what yeah he's been doing that that
that movie with Christina Hendricks from
Mad Men is the lead back god damn it
Julia's not back to Leah's I think he's
back this week cuz he goes sorry shape
he goes seriously bro I need you to find
me a gym in Hollywood do some boxing
some Jitsu ice but no and he goes come
on man I'll sure take this come on man I
need your help you know all the good
gyms it was seriously I'm being dead to
size but no and he goes bro all injured
comedy career he goes one phone call
it's all over
no okay okay okay goes you doing like
any sets this we up yeah goes not it not
if it's me oh all right please don't
not all fun you Jimmy goes give two days
he does that [ __ ] to me he'll just leave
me I got a text
yeah beta my visa yeah he cuz he started
doing some kickboxing or more type
something in Toronto where he's at right
with my boy Joel guy yeah yeah Jim
called res I think I remember Dylan
knows me know Joe's [ __ ] everybody
anytime Joe I put SAS with Joel to lead
with y'all everybody's best friend Joel
he's the best he's the best love it man
he's the guy ray loves a Joel Gerson
Gershon Gerson [ __ ] and he'll take care
you got a great martial arts team I
[ __ ] wish I knew it was called like a
plug it but I know anyway
oh yes in could've ex Jenny are you
going pumped for Australia uh I have
some anxiety about to be honest why but
I don't like to travel the schedule is I
mean I'm not complaining the schedule
such a beast I won't see anything man
yeah I'll and I'd love to go straight to
theater do the show mean great sleep
take off land meeting great theater take
off land
you feel like that's a little crazy mmm
do you think you're gonna sleep no I
don't think you see me Tasos your time
change I would take some ambien
I really would I would take some [ __ ]
ambien
you're not the only doctor out there I
promise it'll help you regulate quickly
you just you're gonna need it or I'll be
groggy is she now cuz if you take it
when you have to sleep you'll at least
you'll get some four hours of really
good sleep for your big so take two yes
I know it's this trouble
yeah there's trouble get addicted oh
just goes back to its not know much [ __ ]
hold on yeah presiding to profile I
talked to my I got friends I have talked
to probe I got to take plenty of it and
then they have trouble that's right
Katie I I sort of take one for the
flight once I'm out that thing that
should be good I'm tired after showing
II was have you ever tried it before no
I have I I you know I took I took yeah I
took it when I was in camp one time I
was so groggy that I got no sleep the
next one show up to in just out my ass
what you know that works you know works
we'd actually part I mean I don't I ran
pin on the Australia them now I don't we
get on our rules there yeah yeah you
could have four Sona bring me some of
the show but don't out them I can bring
my weed pen I usually bring that we
bring Brendan drugs everybody for his
sleeping stored in your game of a pen
stored in your acid prison and bring it
to me
I'll pull it out almost you don't need
to man it's actually legal a guy yeah
but bring you out of here ah no I don't
need to rip the Brahmin about equally
I'm gonna bathroom with me come to the
bathroom so when they give me a weed I'm
like did this come from your help me
with no no man I I get on my car
goodnight I don't want good news and bad
news
it's gonna stink but you will sleep well
what strain is this anus no man it's
[ __ ] regular weed yeah did I get your
regular weed in my [ __ ] face yeah
this anything asus has hepatitis all
over it but take a big old long drag I
mean a sweet yeah I need pooi you have a
little anxiety I mean just a lot going
on here Nelly but we get ready the crook
who uh how do you feel about you yeah
I'm nervous too the flights just I'll
I've said before it's just the freaking
long flight sitting in one place that's
what I'm kind of nervous about right
and then just that everything goes you
know smoothly and well I don't know why
it would it I mean even if we got like a
now you're late I mean I mean like just
a delay that could just screw so much
stuff up so that's that's what I'm or is
that because what are the chances of it
being just Marilyn when it's that long
flight and for nothing on the wrong well
no it's not get out there we're fine
because we have two days to okay to kind
of chill it's with student days before
you have your first rats flying around
Austria that's you mean strange those
two but the first show is the day we
land right no it's not next day oh okay
that's what I was freaking about the
most and that's really good yeah you
always want flying a day early
especially with yeah Australia did what
they wanted to show that day I just feel
as I might want to chill yeah yes can I
chill me sleep let me get a little
acclimated here no man when so when you
took the ambien did you feel okay the
next day probably a Mia is that I would
sleep hard for four hours and wake up
again I always wake up and they say when
they say if you don't get like a solid
eight hours on ambient you're I mean
you're pretty groggy yeah
then they say you can take two ambien
and if you fight through the initial
sleep you'll start to hallucinate again
it's a narcotic items they can't I know
somebody maybe I might never be
recognized that there's some people die
from it too and you can't take it with
you you'd have to take it before you go
to the airport right because if you have
like a well my loads are flights like
what 15 hours 16 hours hmm what I mean
oh you're easy go for a little bit and
take it I my my mother take xanax and
swears by it my mother we had we were
delayed our plane was they were going to
I think Dominican Republic is a whole
family and we had to sleep in the
airport my father goes find the space
right now so we find this little corner
and I slept my mother gave me an aunt I
was an X and I was like alright I'll try
it I'm nerdy I took a xanax and fell
asleep on that [ __ ] that Airport rug
at that Airport although I'm sure it's
clean and I I woke up first of all that
that sanics I woke up like us refresh
like you had to peel me off like I've
been like I've been hit by a [ __ ] you
came out of a coma like I came out of a
you know
yeah he's like my like alien your colon
and seven-year like capsule yeah that's
how I came out I was like Oh making
those noise I was like my whole body my
whole body was just meat yelling neither
am i Michael what the [ __ ] we gonna
steal em [ __ ] could you honey on that
plane that's it I've also heard of
people taking like ambien sleeping pills
and they'll sleep wash position they
don't know do like homeboy cooking a
higher Thanksgiving dinner the whole
cook will make more like what the [ __ ]
this club bro huh quick little turkey
stuffing we're whole words I know a
story about a guy of like took that on
the plane and I got two stories one is
he took that and fell asleep and then
took a [ __ ] in his pants took a poopoo a
plane that feels good that feels good
when you [ __ ] it's a lot of planets as
we go nowhere to go when I gotta walk
today well you also smell like complete
[ __ ]
and then um yeah there's that and then I
know a guy who got in a fight with his
girl he's gonna break up with her on the
plane he took a he had a huge day he
took at ambien or whatever those pills
are or a xanax and she pulled a dick out
and on the plane and left it there and
then he got in trouble for exposing
himself and had legal trouble plagues
yeah how about that
mmm that's good time right so ambien I'm
gonna take my chances I'll get my hands
on one just in case I'm gonna do a
little work my planet is fixing our fly
them do a little work and pop the
ambient see what happens what out and
then also from each in the prescription
stuff you have to have a prescription
otherwise I can get good luck moving him
or asking what he's going when he's
comatose good luck moving him around
let's go buddy you got to pick you up
and get you out of here hey Getty editor
Hey and her people have like
sleepwalking dreams on planes too and
they act out and do crazy yeah just
asleep like when those kids so it might
bring back those memories do my why just
walk in my brother's club and take a
piss enough Dennis Lee really suppose
like what the [ __ ] man
you just I don't remember you Tess walk
yeah that's impressive
thanks man yeah my wife was sitting
there and she's on her phone and she's
howling and I'm like what are you
laughing at
she's just laugh she watched that video
if you chasing me down yeah five times
yeah and then everybody I showed that to
starts cackling dude your forehead is so
much worse yeah
thanks bud well no don't thank me why
you [ __ ] hate it like no it wasn't
that bad and outlook [ __ ] look you did
a flying Kimura and you [ __ ] I told
you that and now I have a scar and I'm
going to be honest what's out Sunday
it was rough house Sunday made no rules
I did poke the bear but here's the thing
I could sue you because I have a
performance and I I make my living off
my looks I definitely do okay oh my god
at least but you [ __ ] up because
didn't do we win you put head gear on I
didn't I didn't but Wayne we were doing
mitts and Wayne hit me a couple times he
was just aggravated I think he
aggravated he didn't mean to but he kind
of caught off the top yeah because it
looks way more let me see looks a little
savage yeah yeah a little son might help
sometimes well yeah you try to see other
son you know what you'll be I I want to
wear a hat yeah oh you could you know
what your new gimmick could be onstage
like the funny beekeeper go up there
like fully dressed and what bro not good
a son you get this huge knots are on
your head not all right my money's
dressed like a beekeeper the beach and
then Raphael and I was like why don't
you look like a chin do you have that
Tiger Tail met lady as a kudamon why
call it did but I took it off but I'll
put it back on the tiger look at that
via bring that up yeah well three the
day they did oh the Freak is afk you're
right it was in England and is that this
at the zoo since you like dedicated life
to animals there's all these pages but
off like it was just a freak act and I
guess freak accident kill the tiger
which I kind of I appreciate that
because it's like a corset killed the
lady when I had a chance why did I know
okay ma bye tiger walked on a deathtrap
man caused by cage fault or human error
33 years old I can't imagine how
terrifying this would be that was the
tiger that doesn't hurt her - huge
animal it was mauled to death she was
safe inside a pelican closure she was
cleaning
oh she thought it was it was barren and
I think just gotten closer wear shoes
work
up here in the zoo look how big it is
look how [ __ ] big that is that a type
of Siberian tiger or something
keep going go down God so she so she was
cleaning and she was in a safe area so
something went wrong with what she touch
using closure that was locked and then
homeboy just so if you lose kinetic by
door was for keeping those beasts
through the windows not clear where the
treasures on through a faulty cage or
human air lock man God can you imagine
no because you'd go quickly but still
[ __ ] oh you said that they would kill
you immediately right yeah but like a
bear they'll grab you about there by the
neck man they grab you a break I said
that's perfect they're saying that they
were showing a not shown but I was
watching this thing they're saying like
all the like people heard screams and
then all the like other zoo employees
would run over there and they're like oh
cuz would you jump in there not guitars
Kanter and [ __ ] you well yeah what do
you do you get a watch in horror it's
awful
do they are they allowed to have like
weapons or someone else I guess stun
guns or guns but I mean when a tiger
grabs a hold of you by the shoulder and
neck it's biting down I mean I'm not
like it's all [ __ ] aside when you
had me in that choke in your 250-pound
man yeah I mean chokes we think about a
tiger like you just it's pretty easy to
kill somebody break somebody's neck if
you're a tiger it's what you do with
rock walls and the power Bob saw
shouldn't kill the animal like [ __ ] man
now it's you someone should be charged
with you know some sort of crime if they
left the gate unlocks up that too i
Shannon had it not the tiger yeah that's
what it says - you're banned from being
on the same side of the tiger and it
says it was open somehow [ __ ] it was
left open by someone it's just a baggage
the thing just was like oh I'm gonna
kill that what it's what they do right
they do they litter like oh [ __ ] look
some Tigers you can't be around with you
can be in the cage with and some Tigers
obviously you can't no not really
none of them unless it's at rent like
these these ones at the zoo you can't
no one's ever in the cage
to them effort god man so she was the
one responsible for opening and closing
it she was she's without a lot of human
error
that's a costly and you work with Tigers
for that long as much of a passion I
feel like or any dangerous animal
elephants chimps did to matter you know
I don't think that's fair to say I don't
especially I don't either but I'm just
saying that fair to say
I'd say most don't die yeah she [ __ ]
up left the cage unlocked this should
have never happened why making a mistake
is fatal you make a mistake in most jobs
I got [ __ ] you work on animals like that
one mistake right oh they found poor
quality safety barriers and primitive
fencing that need replacing what a
bummer got a bet the family probably sue
though huh [ __ ] what else gets you
alright I just saw this one happened
like an hour ago two hours ago
oh no a lot of games LA home vandalized
with Edward graffiti on the outside of
his house like a gate on one of the
houses that he owns but he's not there
often apparel especially not now some
place some a mile an eye takes just
wanted to say was sorry hate kind soul
and spray-paint the n-word front gate so
they just did the front gate and so
nothing too crazy other than a hate
crime Wow and so it goes I mean today
what they just thought they would get in
his head was getting money for them be
finals without your basketball fan can
you be racist they're all black except
for the Europeans other than the help
they all money yeah there's like I'm
Utah lose a dime piece white boy other
than you showed him way to go man oh you
definitely [ __ ] with his head when the
best of all time God what a bunch of
losers what else gets in and I and also
he won't see it but then he's back that
just going to cover it up he did nothing
you're like all right well cool I have
Ted just spray back alright
all right the next one is what we were
talking about earlier yeah
so Kathy Griffin man did some photo
shoot with an artist or swishing
encourage man I ain't looking
furnishings are current times when like
how desperately do you need attention
where let's say I don't like Kath let's
say you don't like President Trump do
you really think this was the best taste
to do why are you the president's fellow
president of our country you know when
look how real it is it looks horrible
and also yeah let's just she looks like
Danny dick with a red wig on what are
you doing well she's she's Kathy's got
her own demons that's for sure and you
know she I should have known better and
also you know Kathy's always been doing
this kind of stuff I feel like she
communicates I feel like she knew this
this gonna cause a big uproar and that's
why she did it stay relevant a little
bit honestly man it's like what I see is
a comedian who's like out of our it
desperate for attention this is my
problem she released a video swarm like
I'm sorry I remember guys I'm with
comedian well yeah okay so you can mean
but how in a me shape or forms that's
funny I'm not the biggest trump
supporter not that's not funny in any
now that's not that's it and what it was
going on with Isis you know plenty of
that in the world where people like Isis
where they don't where they disagree
with their enemies when they disagree
they chop your head off you know a lot
of times you get your head chopped off I
don't know if you're gay or if you're
Jewish or if you're of a different faith
or if you just you know if you just said
there's a rumor that you're an [ __ ]
they'll chop your head off or they'll
put you in a cage let's throw you know
this is old as time right how bad and
how interesting how I'm saying that it
goes on with a comedian is supposed to
be a progressive person and and that
that that's considered funny I don't
think so you so who would laugh abut
that also
okay let's say you pull the comedian
card in what cheaper form is that yet
it's not it's just comic value man I
don't really Cory but then the Obama
comedian so I'm allowed to get away with
it not really no I think she knows all
that and I think she you know well
there's there's Tate I've seen the tape
when she's looking at the the she's on
set and they're looking at pictures you
realize probably a thrown in prison for
this and the time starts laughing she
was it's going to be a big deal
she knows what the [ __ ] ya doin yeah I
just feel I mean I've always found even
if you're not Trump supporter even
though whatever the is have a little
decency but even those people are like
that's not you have some decent like I
think she's Bank on everyone hates time
so they're gonna jump in looking like
this even though it'd be like too much
yeah late because it because it's
something called common decency in
Sevilla Magic she does up to Obama and
Obama head yeah what would happen yeah
exactly
good luck getting any gigs yeah good
luck man and they was playing that stuff
on the other side you know just dude
it's but you know you're doing so she
ate aside man it's kind of such poor
taste yeah also not that creative not
that talented now that's crazy well
that's the thing so so I don't I know
Kathy a little bit of work with Kathy a
couple times and so um so but but I feel
like Kathy somewhere along the line
because she's a talented improv artist
and stuff yeah but a long line I think
some people decide that the way to make
their name is by dishing right by
gossiping by by essentially putting
other people down just like that you see
father Angela Magnolia yesterday man I
just never have chives with that I think
there are more creative what people
volume jive with them yeah you never
there's no longevity in that I mean
you're not gotta keep up in the end I
get any sponsorship deals out of that
you're not getting any TV shows yeah so
I don't know man
I guess you they're talking about you so
it that's what you're looking for but I
don't see it in a good life it's funny
how I look at those things as clumsy
like come on yeah like clumsy like you
know it's magic reiated [ __ ] clumsy
people are clumsy like that's just that
clumsy way of being fine
you know you know that guy is like the
guy is when you do all that dude when
you're hanging out buzz people and
there's always some dude you kind of
know and there's a girl little girl
there and and he says some something
like that there's grass occasion or you
know I would do you know don't crack her
pelvis you're like hey bro [ __ ] off with
your [ __ ] I don't like that [ __ ] you
know I just don't that's the story that
sounds really messed up to that his son
you know in this day and age he sees
this on TV and he doesn't know who Kathy
Griffin is we're just talking about that
like he useed love you there's no idea
idea this crazy-looking woman is holding
up some that looks pretty pretty
realistic input also was just uh was it
in Kuwait
Luka wait there's the bombing 90 people
killed a couple Kabul and Afghanistan so
and then this is your so they're dealing
with real issues it and this is your
shot at humor yeah with all this
[ __ ] going on they're all about
people run it was it origin were just
stabbed over a hate crime because they
were they knew all about this they were
defending a woman who this guy was
hurling racial epithets at this woman it
was a woman and they go ahead to stop
and they both got stabbed kill both of
them kill both no remorse he was like in
court said I'm a patriot it's a
traverses he had he had a history so
you're dealing with all this and this is
what you want to put this what you'll
put out in the world [ __ ] you that's it
who advised you to do this she did you
didn't think I had to dude there's a lot
of moving pieces when you're doing this
yeah I might as an agent she has a
manager there's a photographer there
when you do these things it's not heard
a lot of dining actually that's a that's
a that's a pretty realistic that mad the
blood the picture or wardrobe the entire
team very premeditated I don't give her
no let's not giving out here no there's
a whole team behind it yeah she should
fire everyone or if they told you no you
went along with it god damn man
well not fire because if she fires
everybody she's not taking
responsibility she's responsible for
that for sure she's she did that so how
do you not have a friend guy I get how
my computer but that's a bad look man
he's seen all problems going on in the
world I don't know one person that's
gonna find this funny and even Hillary
Clinton was like that's too much what
the [ __ ] you are daughter yeah under a
dollar oh man talking about killing
president [ __ ] you the Secret Service
you know that I'll stay on it but she
lost a sponsored squatty potty
unless she screwed man no one can get
behind this enhancing Cooper who's like
her main you know side piece he put uh
for the record I am appalled by the
photo shoot Kathy Griffin took part in
it's clearly discussing completely
inappropriate yet no one can get behind
this man now yeah and I can just even
her face and she's just it's all it's
all for attention it's all this
desperate need for
attention so all right the most
desperate I've ever seen mn dot Oh
that'd be a lesson using other people to
prop yourself up hmm I mean laughing and
[ __ ] if you need that lesson you should
just probably just go away forever huh
if you need a lesson that not to do that
yeah that's crazy to me man what else he
had tune all right this one a guy who
claimed his girlfriend at the time
choked on his penis cuz it's so big and
that's how she died that was his defense
and he's actually and he got found not
guilty
he got off and he's gonna show his dick
today today he and he said he didn't
call the police he's 65 was humiliated
man is just cleared of strangling
Francisco Martinez 60 in Florida
claims girlfriend for four months choked
to death on his large penis so basically
she's deep throwing it and he thought it
was good time he had made it killing her
but tonight is deliberate with persons
loaded funny motion sure to show his
penis to the jury show how huge we must
had a Hogg low soul and I guess said
they found blood and semen at the scene
he left her there on the bed she'd been
dead for 24 hours I don't get that [ __ ]
he was obviously he obviously for real
killed her with his bike holding her
down on his dick and so so he that's
murder isn't it I mean that is probably
high enough and then our dad that
bothers oh no signs of the drama
it was surrounded by blood and cement he
got off on killing her um you know with
the high expression was arrested after
he message daughter and ex-girlfriends
and he did something bad he said he
children's if your but his defense later
that he didn't say he strangled her and
he got off nice yeah damn this is some
dark [ __ ] it's dark [ __ ] that is he
obviously held her down on his dong
because she died if the entire Jersey I
get it man he must have the fattest dick
we thought about fat dick is about the
fact that he he held her down on it yeah
but if it's [ __ ] she would have her nap
for every been to pull back when it's
too much but if it's that big because if
it was small you have no what the Lord's
like we can't oh yeah but it was so spec
you mean yeah like it was a bit much
with a big old piece
show the journey went you know what
you're right think about that thing to
slay entire jury yeah but they didn't
show his dick hi yes no they did he said
he had to show his dick to the jury they
said they wanted him they wanted to his
defense wanted to show the jury it's a
very ominous but variance and they
camera but I'm not guilty
breathe you should least do a little
time even involuntary man's photo but I
mean but again like you were holding her
down on your on your dawn but they said
no signs of struggle yeah nothing like
that and I looking at the back of her
[ __ ] throat you know I'm saying no
but if you know we know chinois
scratches Hamar held a dead body
decomposing for 24 to 48 hours before he
called the cop but you would think he
likes you like if she was struggling
like trying to fight him off you have
marks on his thighs I like to
interesting her ass like she would put
up a fight she just I can be like oh
please stop she said maybe she may tweak
here's here's an idea I mean and this is
very possible they were into rough sex
play she got off on that and she like
maybe they done stuff where he would
because they're people choked her groped
you choked me unconscious or choking
till I passed out he yeah all that [ __ ]
people are in the rough [ __ ] and crazy
[ __ ] so maybe they were doing that maybe
he would you know make her pass out on
his that he got off on that she got off
on that and it went too far and she just
died that's possible you don't see yet
[ __ ] and something happened I just saw
this underneath this so I'm so hard
right now this just happens getting
[ __ ] up passenger tackled after trying
to hijack a Malaysia Airlines plane if
you're dumb enough trying to hijack
playing these days we all know how it
ends everyone's jacking your ass yeah
yeah
you can get more more than a rug burn on
your head like I did oh man well when
we're flying Australia so hopefully I'm
not an ambien I'm awake for this is
nobody that's why I got a problems with
you in close quarters I'm [ __ ] them
every boy I got some gravy a chin did
you forget stammer out we need a blast
this out for the thing if it's six dudes
is six you're gonna do some work though
Olay don't let that worn they're all gay
too
would you say tunes light from Mel born
to call mom poor to Australia shortly
after takeoff well
okay that doesn't make me feel good no
kidding I have anxiety chin did you hug
the [ __ ] business went up a bomb
scare god damn it - man well now how
about this what do you think about this
um you know the bull that's in wall
street the sculpture yeah so during the
National Women's History Month
they another sculptor put a little grill
sculpture in front of it by kind of
defying the bull to show the power of
women
so the original sculptor thought that
was messed up copyright trademark
infringement cuz it's messing with his
artwork oh yeah alright so another
sculptor was on the side of the main
sculptor and he put a dog peeing on the
girl - Larry got taken down her like
three hours oh I love all of they took
it down in two hours I loved it that's a
war of art that's a great Batman that's
that's a war of ideas of art of imagery
creativity it's not blowing people up
yeah cutting heads on me I [ __ ]
hilarious it's funny right but they took
that dog pissing on the lady down like
three hours because the roots are
artists who did the bull like no that's
not it's not bent it's not saying that's
attacking people it's intimidating the
little girl more girls man like that
[ __ ] up the whole vision of us yeah
you guys put this female in front of
this little girl yeah hilarious a guy
that built the dog pissing on the girl
bo the original guy suing the sculptor
of the girl whoever funded the sculptor
of the girl the state you know this
story is a it's kind of sad but kind of
nice so this little kid had a birthday
party no one showed up to his birthday
and this is his eighth birthday party
his mom said that during his sixth
birthday party it happened before he was
devastated and mom quit inviting
everyone so she's like I can't have this
anymore so she drove to the local police
station to ask if a cop could come by to
celebrate his birthday with them then
the whole like squad came by with
firefighters and everything else because
men could a little homie has no friends
and say mama it's throwing these goddamn
parties that's all kidding
I with a kid that age man that's oh dude
that's devastating your mind of it rings
you forgot that his friends ain't come
over for his birthday the prize on is
Fred Oh kids are dicks [ __ ] man lots of
mom she's a bad organizer maybe she was
like wait no took today tomorrow and the
kids like me she's like a living
together as a day off that's how I
really hey guys we're having a party in
a couple hours
well I'm on my way to Santa Barbara yeah
okay sorry huh that's such a bummer
listos please men save the day we've
been in firefighting once man that's it
stop making for a lot jr. it was enough
to make doing well yeah I'm Eric crying
to my desk and I don't have any friends
you feel like a [ __ ] weirdo me I've
known to talk to you and me my social
animals man without friends it's bad for
your health actually today isolate hey
your mom let's stop doing these huge
[ __ ] bastards that no one's come to
do huh yeah hey your kids not the
[ __ ] Great Gatsby let's relax on the
birthday back what would this study they
just did about that we're we're friends
having friends is good for your health
like it did you really need a study for
that - I do look first like no but they
say people from this just in having
friends is beneficial evil friends
remember your light communities like
they even when they practice unhealthy
eating habits and stuff smoke they live
way longer which you know would make
sense your your you have a support
system you're not as stressed you're not
as isolated one of the biggest things
that for old people is isolation is
loneliness well when they when they lose
their all that Miamian or when they lose
their companions they died shortly after
yeah yeah look Nene studies for the idea
for babies in hospitals they have
somebody goes around and touches the
babies when they don't have parents
where the orphans and stuff if you don't
touch a baby if you don't touch a
newborn all the way through they will
die they have to be touched it's called
failure to thrive so they actually have
to hire people to pick the babies up and
hold them yeah there's be extra job they
pick up the baby yeah pretty cool job
yeah love me a nice baby what else yes
you love it nice bait Holly got some
more I'm a baby fan this chick you know
who my Ben I don't
oh that's good wieners girls yeah and
she just divorced them or she filed for
divorce recently because he got
convicted or he actually had pleaded
guilty to texting a minor like sexting
of a girl and baby next to him his baby
it was talking that was a different one
she's hot he sent ones before didn't she
Hillary Clinton yes head of creator
yes stop stop yeah and I am manager deep
sought him back home now
dude I'll tell you what giving up on a
weiner is the cockroach of human being
here that [ __ ] when he's down he
will not die I bet he has the best
stroke game in the business she can do
whatever he wants and she keeps taking
them back well she's got to be doing his
job and the baby she loves him she
[ __ ] loves him and he that's
impressive because that's twice he's
[ __ ] up and she's bringing her back
any time
I say good for Huma I say she loves the
man [ __ ] everybody they're trying to
make it work regardless she she's a
forgiving human being god bless you and
[ __ ] Anthony Weiner whoa he's a dead
[ __ ] man and no doubt he's a bad
[ __ ] he must be doing something
he's body wh he next crane dude he's
bodied up and has a piece on him and
stuff going on here amazing cuz she
cannot get rid of him they decide for
another year he's moving back in yeah
he's got a register as a sex offender be
part of the plea deal with the Manhattan
whoa nevermind for crazy ass place -
it's like 11,500 months yeah it's wonder
man hey he'll be able to go on at the
lecture circuit he'll find his way back
I mean that's president that's tough
that's tough but you know what god bless
both of them they're trying to make
their relationship work despite it all
yes he's a [ __ ] up I love people had
to do that dog you know what I mean I'll
[ __ ] we love each other she takes him
back the long-suffering woman I'm
impressed with her I don't know we think
do you think I'm a little too crunk
about this I just like when people like
they just can't stay away from each
other no matter what
that's love man yeah by the way I really
low self-esteem she's Erebus when I and
he's Jewish
it's like how the you know it's like the
age-old conflict finding away parish
yeah yes we nerd avidin c IC wiener
being this killer top sex drive means I
stop I see her she's killing it in her
River it has low self-esteem because any
girl worth their salts gonna move oh
[ __ ] or she blames herself maybe for the
fact she knows I'm staying at attention
or sex or what everyone own damn damn
that's it
some people refuse to quit I ain't
quittin she's just scared maybe a
thunder on this goblin or hey she's got
a five-year-old son she wants her son
and son to grow up with with her dad
with her degenerate dad who keeps taking
dick pics with him instead
he's a little oral argument be I don't
know man I'm not there in that house not
in their head I don't know yeah they're
both intelligent people and making that
choice business-wise that intelligent I
don't know about social and life in
general but he's what I mean think about
it keep him very I mean back in have you
seen the documentary no I hear I hear
you'll love if you like him now you'll
love what's that thing I'm surprising up
for gonna be president he's got a sense
of humor and all that [ __ ] ah he's just
a beast like he's not snotty were sigh
he's a snob yeah like [ __ ] he likes to
[ __ ] he does hey it's possible he's a
really effective good guy who just likes
[ __ ] can't help himself he's a sex
addict yeah that's what he claims are a
lot of people food addicts alcohol
addicts drug addicts he's a sex addict
powerful men yeah what else you got gin
all right this is a pretty big douchebag
I don't know if you guys seen this
before but he some random white guy this
is vedera
day he was opening up a 7-eleven door
for this guy with cerebral palsy and it
seemed like he was a nice dude all right
he's holding the door open and the guy
selva palsy obviously has a little bit
of a stumble to his walk is he drunk
no he's not his what's his condition so
almost guys making fun of him
automatically right and this is just
crazy so he's making fun um so the guy
comes back out and the guy is imitating
his walking right next to him and then
you'll see this for no reason closet and
they say [ __ ] and that guy just yet
because arranger walks by nothing out to
get out the back pick the biggest [ __ ]
in this whole video does nothing and
when a woman walks out trying to figure
what's going on dude why did you punch
him for no reason Wow
so it turns out
this dude the douchebag he has such a
horrible frickin rap sheet he Rob's from
veterans cemeteries oh my god when you
get on a sociopath when you get hold of
gun kill him yeah yeah he's a total
sociopath he saw 2000c ropes was he
once we robbed marks graves put him in
jail and see what happens to him don't
[ __ ] him up it was like completely
unprovoked is just just a douche bag he
pleaded guilty to stealing hundreds of
bronze flag holders from the vets burial
site he did by the way this little piece
of [ __ ] nearly $250,000 outsells that's
what a real piece of [ __ ] looks and
conviction for theft of a motor vehicle
hope they catch this guy or they got him
oh they got they got him so man of the
the guys and you know there's a this a
bit of stretch in prison in jail they're
gonna [ __ ] that guy hopefully hopefully
hopefully hey ready hopefully they
[ __ ] I kill him like I see that guy
and I'm like do you really need to be
alive I mean does he i Greeley odds what
good does he do the guy that need to be
alive because I to be murderous about it
but like is he like that's the kind of
guy if he died I'd be like ah cool I'd
be happy if you died I was walking off
the car hit him that made me feel way
out about the situation I'm sure he's
got something wrong with his brain but I
don't care like I don't care I think you
know so I could punch that poor guy then
your steal from bet you know don't kill
him but put him away forever like hi why
don't you wave him you know I don't get
it yeah great taxpayers paid for this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah to live the rest of days out in
prison who's gonna keep doing stuff like
that and worse well that's the time he's
been caught for yeah what else has he
done exactly got bad [ __ ] all the time
exactly steer woman with a sketch it
being so crazy that's makes you feel
sick this one so a guy didn't do well on
his test and his way of trying to make
up for it was to hold his teacher his
her door closed and say please give me
another chance to finish this test a
smart guy so he's desperate to retake
the test
and that's basically kidnapping right
yeah so he went to jail for that he'd
really think that was gonna work out he
was desperate and then he
so you see here he actually like sell on
the ground you know crying when he when
he was inside the room with her to you
know make her change her mind to give
him a yesterday he's so bad I've never
won anything that looks in my life my
god relax man when I was in jail I
walked to my future my hip to teacher I
gave me a C - I've done no work on a
paper and I go why'd you give me a C - I
was like I should buy produce well did
you like like lay my why did you give me
a c-minus on this and he goes he was
just really like a distinguished
professor he looked with a reviews I
can't he come through it okay he tells
me my [ __ ] rack and he goes I bet he was
a a good because so I don't why this
morning because because because the
paper is undernourished you know husk
that's like oh yeah are you professor
Carr you've seen 1 million baby lock off
I spent exactly 10 minutes on the
because the paper is undernourished what
else we get soon look I got one more
like you're breaking of uh not giving up
on love do you remember this story from
many years ago sure do
my teacher Valerie Letourneau is like
one of the most famous cases she was 34
the he's like a Samoan Theatre Islander
kid he was 13 and they had sex multiple
times they fell in love she went to jail
for like seven years when she got out
they got married black two had kids what
everything why does she look a thousand
times better than him yeah yeah he looks
like Tiger would he mugshot yeah he
didn't love you know give that great
yeah it's like pure [ __ ] he meanwhile
she's flourishing oh she's a dime piece
and now I want a waiver when the [ __ ]
were these hot creatures trying to [ __ ]
their students when I was a kid did you
ever have a teacher make a pass psycho
never won no and I loved all of them he
- but it definitely worked
I wouldn't done any any other sure woman
anything oh but just gosh no one gave me
a [ __ ] Abba
not a thing not a glance nothing not a
glance I remember to jump through that
[ __ ] did oh my god and I'm on an
earth watching exhibition I was studying
orangutan in the middle of the [ __ ]
Indonesian rainforest with my sister and
there was a woman there she was a
scientist and she was older and I was a
I showed her how to do a wheel kick and
I was like so yeah I would do whatever I
could I'm in a war sol-gel yeah my
sister's like on he doesn't live alone
my dad pays for everything he goes to
college my dad pays his rent just
[ __ ] outed me I was like she didn't
give me [ __ ] and then she was dating
another side it was like 30 and
six-foot-four [ __ ] Dave two teenage
dollars now - I have to correct myself
did I say Valerie Letourneau now I might
have very okay like it's a Mary Kay
Letourneau well they finally his ever
really follow Lou ah [ __ ] phone okay I
didn't get a haircut though Billy hey
Billy kids there any we could do
anything with your wardrobe before
entertainment tonight Kim snap this yeah
she's a doll damn yeah she's a cutie
patootie but I never working again but
super attracted her and older she did
time for love that's impressive she's a
little older now she did time boys
really young yeah so how old was she 34
34 he was 13 that's kind of okay now
okay so now 33 news 13 and how old how
old are they now
oh now my third he's ready oh no however
reports claimed as a couple actually
splitting up yeah I've been having
issues for a while now yeah so that's
what they tried to work through them but
it didn't work they're still committed
to being good pencil children yeah no
[ __ ] it didn't work so he filed for
separation and then she child another
daughter ma'am to dismiss the separation
so she's super like she can't let it go
you're like you can't really do anything
about that she crazy
it's just crazy with love crazy for corn
crazy crazy with love she crazy a
teacher crazy Oh world she that's tough
that's that's a crazy love story though
it is that's like from that's my boy
Pepsi oh then I'm saying this is
hilarious I was making my nephews laugh
so [ __ ] hard because my wife's gonna
be 40
in a year and I and I was we were at
dinner the whole family and I kept going
uh she's gonna be 40 ooh blue you know
like anybody over for you they were
[ __ ] dying so I was like nah but I
mean I think we're gonna work through it
and just cuz she's boring
you know like an usual younger than me
um she still looks good though
dang look at that teacher though man
he's a DJ now looks like his celebrity
day yeah what is he doing hmm anyway
listen Matt seven [ __ ] years seven
years well he was 13 yeah she was 34
thundersense Thank You kids
yeah that would be 17 18 19 20 so honey
when years older that's a lot he thinks
he's real fly that picture what else you
got hurt other not liked it but us yet
you sure aren't that's good I know I
know but I got a page hiya Pete dude
yeah so um here's my dropping knowledge
I want people to be aware of a very
human tendency that all of us do which
is the fact that our feelings control
and run our thinking for the most part
like our belief system so we're talking
about confirmation bias like let's take
certain you know certain questions like
and I'm reading from from this great arc
on New York Times I read well our
magazines I have a problem with but like
for example you hear a lot of like
political disagreements on things like
between liberals and conservatives
things like it's human activity
responsible for global warming do guns
make society safer is immigration
harmful to the economy you know you get
these questions right so they're
complicated questions but our point of
view on those questions as human beings
should change according to the evidence
but the fact of the matter is most of us
don't even listen or look at the
evidence or accept the evidence we don't
change our mind about being open-minded
I'm talking about being open to you know
new information the be open-minded yeah
and all but also also sometimes new
information is presented to you where
they say you know it's basically like
what they you know what do you know the
expression empirical evidence is
it's a very important concept empirical
evidence is what you based science on so
measurable evidence here a lot of
courtrooms yes yes and and so you know a
medicine works for somebody because
there's a there's you can measure that
effect or you know a bomb works for that
matter because you can measure its
explosive detonation and all that stuff
so empirical evidence is very important
we should use empirical evidence for a
lot of our point of view on things and
we should use empirical vitamins a lot
of times to make a decision based on you
know where we're going to vote changing
our mind is fine based on empirical
evidence but the fact is that we all
suffer for something called confirmation
bias okay and that's a psychological
time reading this but it's a
psychological tendency to favorite
information that confirms your beliefs
and disfavor information that counters
them okay we live a long time yeah we do
and so this my my driver knows a bit
just take some inventory about what you
believe what you think and pay attention
to how much of it is driven by your
actual feelings your prejudices your
fears because the truth of the matter is
as I get older I start to realize that
more and more I don't know as much as
I'd like to I will tend to also you know
what else we do we also kind of find
ourselves cherry-picking information to
tell people what it is they actually
want to hear doctors do this a lot where
they don't really want you to hear
something bad poem it is really hard for
them politicians yeah and we all want to
hear we don't want the fact that it's
there's there's not real truth there we
do this when we buy houses when we buy
stuff we spend too much money it's like
I want the facts to run in my favor so
I'm going to believe what and listen to
what I want not what's all there so just
be aware that take a little inventory
it's very [ __ ] important mm-hm
you're gonna be an Irvine buddy you got
dang right I'm gonna be in our hook that
round 9th and 10th
Irvine improv is to get you fat a.com
and then my ass is heads Australia
they're only tickets left in Auckland
which is the biggest dealer
we sold the most tickets there it's on
what we we're close to selling out you
guys are the only ones not sold out
Oakland and then the early show in
Sydney that might be sold out there
might be some there I'm not sure tak
calm for all those every other shown
that Australian New Zealand tour is sold
out and I will be in New York on June
22nd at Gotham comedy club get your
tickets now peep at kake.com mining town
in Irvine get them while they're hot
we're releasing tea fat K summer teas
coming up and tanks coming up soon oh
yeah this is the finally kid we're out